Pam when you were taking the adderall
Diaries as the memoir and then adapting
it into a screenplay how much did you
embellish the drug use and sex scenes or
did you try to tone them down a bit did
you want a drug you said the sex scenes
are actually toned down quite a bit I
think that was something that Stephen
was very interested in the book and I
was lost interested in the film because
you know if to me this film was about
the relationships between these
characters and how consequences in that
in those relationships led to a
realization in the main characters so
that his you know unusual sex life and
his pretty moderate drug use are both
parts of that and parts of who you are
who he is but to me those were both sort
of elements of a character and I think
that you know S&M is is all over the
media all over cinema right now and so
to me it wasn't as shocking as it maybe
was in like 2008 when he was writing the
book in 2009 when it came out so it's it
seemed pretty easy to meet it except
that that's a part of this guy's life
and that his adderall use is a part of
his life and we didn't really need to
talk about it that much it's just part
of who he is sure James I think you've
said previously that Stephen writing the
book was not just a memoir he was trying
to create a piece of art okay how much
do you feel about that and your own work
because there's a lot of similarities it
seems like between the two of you were
both very passionate you go against the
grain you're both writers I think maybe
I was trying to define what the book was
more meaning it's not just a straight
memoir you know this book is not just
that I did this then I did this then I
did this then I did this it's more
there's there's a more complicated kind
of structure or approach here where the
way that he's remembering things become
is focused on and that began he starts
to question or highlight that process in
himself and extend it to all of us that
you know we edit and tell our our
stories in particular ways both to
ourselves and to others for me the books
that I've written are you know
categorized as as fiction I certainly
use some of my own experiences and those
those books but they are very much
you know fiction so I think I'm doing
something a little different right one
of my favorite quotes is actually that
to step out of our own story and then
once we do we see the world differently
and the people around us differently did
the two of you experienced that in your
own life having watched Steven in his
process and whether his story was
totally true or not did you have any of
your own revelations about your life
part of the appeal for me in telling the
story was the opportunity to look at
places in my own life where my narrative
doesn't match someone else's I think
everybody tells the story of a breakup
differently a relationship with a parent
and that's fascinating it's it's not
malicious it's not fought it's part of
who we are we're narrative machines and
we need to make sense of who we are and
we need to make sense of what's happened
to us
well my you know my story about myself
is goes up in conflict with sort of a
public persona you know almost all the
time you know I I am a public
personality and often times I don't
think that what's projected out there is
me but I've come to accept that is you
know somebody that sort of lives half of
his life in public I know that I can't
control that version of myself that
story that is being told by a big
collective or through you know a lot of
different outlets
it's certainly contrast with who I think
I am but I also have kind of reconciled
myself with it that it's just part of my
life